there are just 17 days to go until the
2018 midterm elections and with control
of both houses of Congress and 36
governor's mansions at stake there are
new concerns about the security of
America's election systems on Friday US
intelligence agency stated that Russia
China Iran and other countries are
engaged in active efforts to influence
voters hours later the Justice
Department announced the indictment of a
Russian woman making her the first
person charged with interfering in the
2018 election for more were joined by
Ian van de Walker senior counsel at the
Brennan Center for Justice at NYU law
school here in New York and good morning
morning let's start with this indictment
how did they find this woman and what is
she accused of she is use accused of
being the accountant to the organization
that was involved in the February
indictment and has long been known to be
a major organization interfering in
elections by essentially paying Russian
trolls to post on social media
pretending to be Americans and talking
about American politics to influence
American politics
federal prosecutors today are federal
prosecutors I should say are saying that
they're using the same tactics that they
used back in 2016 yes yes a lot of in
fact the exact same tactics some of the
even the same accounts were involved
which shows that we really haven't yet
closed the doors from 2016 or learn
those lessons how far beyond social
media are they going here I mean there
have been attempts to sort of target you
know structures like databases
registration rolls poll our polling
stations secure I mean how secure are we
look hackers are always trying to attack
voter registration systems and anything
anything that they can touch but there's
no evidence that any votes have been
changed any voter registration databases
have been changed and we have election
officials working around the clock to
keep that safe in in concert with DHS
the FBI and other federal agencies there
were so much uproar right after the 2016
election about this and then it went
away and you mentioned this idea that
things haven't changed we've heard some
talk about it with social media
companies but what about Congress why
have they not done
anything about this that's a tricky
problem it's I think that Congress that
there have been bills there's a there's
bills to increase transparency online
which would leave trolls with fewer
places to hide and give law enforcement
more of the kind of information that
they've used to create these indictments
and the February indictments and
unfortunately those bills haven't moved
but you know we hope to see movement
after the election and there's been some
finger-pointing at both Iran and China
what more do we know about that as
influencers very little I mean Iran was
caught doing the same kind of thing
using fake accounts to pretend to be
Americans to talk about American
politics to sort of sow discord and have
Americans fighting with each other
China we know that they spend millions
on legal reported lobbying but there's
nothing publicly known about this kind
of election interference that the the
Russians have been known to engage in
this the social media the indictment
points to sort of specific instances of
use of social media and it largely aimed
mostly at confusion and disruption
correct what exactly they try they have
they done yeah the interesting thing is
they have multiple accounts and they're
just saying the exact opposite thing so
that would be one side saying you know
pumping up President Trump and saying
he's what we need another side attacking
him from the sort of liberal perspective
so they're really not articulating a
single viewpoint what they want is to so
division they want Americans at each
other's throats and they want Americans
distrusting our system of democracy that
is distrusting the voting booth there's
trusting each other and each other's
political parties so that's the thing
that we really need to be aware of and
what's and what's clear and this is it's
it's an ongoing process it's it goes
back to 2016 but it continues now
absolutely and they will be going
continuing going into 2020 for all we
know so if Congress isn't doing anything
what can we do I think you know
everybody should be aware that this
stuff is going on when you're when you
see a political post on social media
think about it do I know where this is
coming from can I confirm it from an
independent source do I really want to
inject this into the discourse and have
my friends be repeating this kind of
thing those are the things that
individuals can do all right Ian van de
Vaca thank you so much for being with us
this morning thank you